he's betrayed the uniform he wore
but should sex killer wayne cousins ever
have been allowed to become a policeman
in dover two years before he joined the
metropolitan police
cousins was suspected of indecent
exposure
no action was taken days before he raped
and murdered sarah everard he was
suspected of more indecent exposure
he wasn't questioned a woman who was
abused and then raped by her policeman
husband
described how his own force failed to
take any action against him
the ripple effect of violence by the
police and the impact of the police not
dealing with it
that caused me so much pain i can't
express enough and it means i can't
report other crimes i've had since
i've been drugged and sexually assaulted
and left unconscious
and i can't report it because i can't go
to the police because i think they might
be a rapist
or an abuser because they harboured my
ex-husband until his retirement
i know i'll never get justice and
justice is really important
it kills people when they can't get
justice we really need to fix it because
there's nowhere for people like me to go
solicitor harriet wistrich said police
must treat
low-level sex crimes more seriously
there's always um more than one bad
apple um
unfortunately uh i mean you know
obviously what happened
you know amounting to a murder is
particularly alarming
but if you don't tackle um you know
the lower level offending you know that
that's the risk that the
characters like weighing cousins can um
you know
become worse and and you know we we see
a lot of
bad ends uh with with lower level uh
abuse sexual harassment domestic abuse
not being dealt with effectively cousins
is a waiting sentence for the kidnap
rape and murder of sarah everard the
marketing executive
he snatched as she walked home in south
london in march
the police watchdog the iopc is
investigating why nothing came of the
earlier allegations against cousins
why police took no action ten officers
face
misconduct charges the fallout from the
wayne cousins case means more pressure
on cressida dick
scotland yards commissioner the
metropolitan police said
cousins was vetted when he joined the
force in 2018
campaigners say his crimes show that
that process
in all police forces need to be more
vigorous
martin brunt sky news